welcome to the show that puts you at the
center of the national conversation
talking about the issues that matter to
you the most
tonight
immigration
issue that has tormented Government
after Covenant for decades that many
believe lay behind brexit tonight it has
the Home Secretary under pressure again
has already resigned once admitting that
she broke the rules that govern
ministerial conduct
now she's back but chaos certain
overcrowded Asylum processing center in
Kent has some even those on her own side
wondering whether she'll make it through
Halloween
I'm Trevor Phillips and this is the
great debate
[Applause]
tonight the MPS Knocking At Home
Secretary suela bravman's door won't be
asking for treats they want answers
why are there more than twice as many
Asylum Seekers as they should be at
manston immigration processing center in
Kent
did she ignore legal advice that might
have allowed more accommodation to
relieve the pressure
and what's she going to do about what
she herself today called our broken
Asylum system and does she even have a
plan to tackle The Wider labor shortages
that are crippling the economy
as ever our viewers panel from around
the country and indeed around the world
well have their say and they will tell
their stories
and joining us in the studio tonight are
a conservative MP for Dover Natalie
elfick
Labor's Shadow immigration Minister
Stephen kinnick
the Barrister former Asylum seeker and
human rights campaigner adironke apata
and the deputy director of the migration
Observatory Rob McNeil
the big question tonight
how do we solve Britain's immigration
dilemma
the cost of our Asylum system has topped
two billion pounds a year the Home
Secretary is under growing pressure over
the treatment of refugees and migrants
when they arrive in the UK 4 000 people
in a facility that was designed to hold
1500 that is only unacceptable let's
stop pretending that they are all
refugees in distress the whole country
knows that that is not true
[Applause]
they should send them to Rwanda and them
that can't go to Rwanda send them back
to France
[Music]
[Applause]
there is absolutely nothing racist about
wanting Britain to have secure borders
that work
we saw dozens of migrants carrying a
boat to the sea in full sight of French
police officers who did nothing to stop
them
[Applause]
[Music]
take that
it's not sustainable to keep doing this
[Music]
as we always do with our viewers panel
joining us on the screen and talk to
John Soderberg John you're in Lancaster
I think
that's right good evening
good evening John your thoughts
well um if we look at the current issue
it's probably one of two problems the
first part of the problem is getting to
our Waters in this instance or on our
Shores and the second problem is what we
do with them I'm really focusing on the
first part of it on that I'm concerned
that France in particular is turning a
blind eye to the immigrants that are
coming into this country in this manner
I.E the small boats and this begs the
question as to whether the UK is
allowing France to ignore tens of
thousands of illegal immigrants
departing from their Shores each year
and indeed up to the 10th month which is
finishing today it's a record forty
thousand uh immigrants and we had 28 000
last year to give it some context so my
question to the panel is what is
France's role in all of this thank you
very much for that John we'll come back
in a second let's speak to Victoria
skulls Victoria I think you're in
Sunbury on Thames and you also have a
question for our panel
yes so whilst I support workers coming
over to do skilled jobs and they should
be in this country to build help build
out infrastructure what I don't believe
in is the illegal immigrants and
migrants coming over on the boats
how can we the UK financially support
those from other countries when we can't
look after our own
so my question is how can we stop the
small boats
Victoria thank you very much well
there's a direct question from
Victorious gold
how do we stop the small boats
Natalie elfick this is your Shore isn't
it it certainly is and it's very much my
sure that the boats are arriving into uh
they come into the Dover facility and I
think in those questions it's absolutely
hit the nail on the head that these are
boats that are leaving from France and
there's absolutely no need for anyone to
get in one of these small boats is
illegal immigration that's run by
criminal gangs and it's incredibly
dangerous just last year 27 lives were
lost in a single day more than 100
people are thought lost not accounted
for it's really important that we
actually take action on the French side
they stop the boats getting in the water
and that we actually also save lives in
the process so you you would
specifically how would you stop those
boats how would they actually be held up
well I'd like to see joint patrols with
France on the beaches military patrols
well I think joint patrols with our
border officers and their border
officers indeed with other European
Partners as well I think it's absolutely
vital that that we actually give that
support they need to have more bodies on
the ground but also as we've seen in
some of that footage I'm sorry to say
you know sometimes they have been
standing by even shockingly when women
and children have been put on those
boots and the French haven't intervened
in that so that's got to change we've
got to tackle it first and foremost in
France on their Shores Stephen kiddick
um I think we're spending something
north of 100 million pounds a year
on helping France Patrol that bit of its
Shore that looks towards the White
Cliffs of Dover we're getting our value
for money my understanding is that about
50 of those who attempt to cross are
being stopped so that's clearly not good
enough
um and there's massive room for
improvement the government needs to
rebuild its relationship with the French
government which has not gone into a
good place I would say generally
speaking since uh brexit and of course
uh the previous prime minister's
comments about not being sure whether
president Macau is a friend or a foe
were deeply unhelpful but to get to the
heart of this issue we've got to sort
out the processing of Asylum claims in
the UK because that system has
completely collapsed and the result of
that is that those people who want to
come across on small boats know that
once they got they've got to the UK
they'll be here for at least two three
or four or five years because the system
has collapsed so if we actually got to
the heart of the matter speeding up the
processing which means resourcing the
home office properly with decision
makers and caseworkers you would then if
you were going to pay 10 thousand
dollars to a people's per people
Smuggler you'd think twice if you knew
that within two or three months your
claim could well be rejected and you
could well be sent back but if you know
you're going to be in the UK for two
three or four years even in limbo it's a
gamble worth taking well you brought
that up student
um isn't the real reason that they know
that they will not uh be sent off
somewhere else is because in January
2021 we uh after leaving the EU came out
of what was called the Dublin convention
which meant that we could return uh
people who landed here very quickly very
swiftly to uh countries on the continent
where they might have been fingerprinted
and identified but when we came out
actually we couldn't do that anymore and
in fact if you look at the numbers it's
quite striking 2020 fewer than 9 000
coming across on the boat 2021 29 000.
yeah isn't that the reason you are
absolutely right and when you you
combine that the fact that the former
prime minister but one Boris Johnson
completely botched to the brexit
negotiations and failed to negotiate a
successor to the Dublin convention
combine that with the collapse of
processing of Asylum claims in the home
office you have a perfect storm which
has led to these massive backlogs and
has acted as a magnet for more and more
people wanting to come over I don't
listen about home office incompetence
and so on so forth but do you think that
actually at the root of this there's
bigger forces here one of which we've
just been discussing
my thinking is this
it is not something that anybody wants
to do wants to go on the small boat
that is wanting to have confidence with
death
it's been mentioned here that children
and women
die on those boats
and that's not what should happen
what should happen
is
for governments to provide safe Passage
because when there is safe passage we
can cut off the
people Smugglers
and people would not die unnecessarily
that is more of compassion people can
come into the UK
through what we can call the legal Ruth
which is quite safe for them and then
they can claim Asylum there would not be
this backlog and the possibility of
people dying
Kerry and Jones you asked the question
about this I just heard what adironke
has said that actually nobody really
wants to get on a boat that actually
there must be better ways of doing this
uh you are there in Dover
um you're seeing
uh what's coming at what's what's coming
into the town what do you how do you
respond to what's been said
Kerry and we uh Kerry and we had a bit
of trouble with your sound there I
wonder if you could just start again
because I I know that you've had a
direct experience with meeting some of
the migrants
yes I live I live directly on one of the
routes that is used
when they come in in the dinghies off of
the beaches my house is literally around
the corner from the beach and I had
somebody in August actually
caught half over my back gate who
petrified me to the point of I now sleep
with a sledgehammer I'm a single parent
so a six-year-old autistic little girl
that must be
terrifying
do you absolutely serious anything do
you understand though what adiranka is
saying here that it um would take
something to make somebody take the risk
of getting on these boats Crossing one
of the busiest sea Lanes in the world
with the knowledge that people have uh
been tipped out people have drowned on
that Crossing
oh yes they definitely do I mean
um where I live you actually see the
Search and Rescue helicopters so I know
firsthand that it does and I totally
agree with what she was saying there
does need to be a safe route women and
children should not come this way
whatsoever
Natalie alfit we've got a
if you like a collision of two ghastly
things here the awful problem of the
people who are risking their lives and
somebody who's scared out of her wits
no absolutely and that situation of the
boat's Landing is on a number of the
coastal Villages and areas in my
constituency of Dover and deal and it's
been going on for a very long time and
people do get extremely frightened and I
completely understand their concerns but
it shouldn't be landing on the beaches
people shouldn't be having those
experiences so it's really vital that we
get a grip of this issue turning to that
question as to whether people are safe
people are safe in France there is no
reason to be getting in one of these
small boats it's absolutely vital that
people claim Asylum if they need help
and assistance in France or one of the
many other safe countries that they come
to if we go down another route I think
we just put more into the hands of the
criminal gangs and that's what we've
seen this problem getting worse and
worse and worse we really need to tackle
it and tackle it on the French side to
make sure that we work with the with
France on the beaches and across the
channel in that way if migrants and
people Smugglers know they can't get
across the country in a small boat it
will stop
Rob McNair why is it not possible
to stop people leaving the beaches at
Calais well I think one of the first
things we should probably bear in mind
is that there's a sort of presumption in
a lot of these conversations that France
isn't doing anything to try and address
this problem well I mean other than
obviously the patrols on the beach but
France has seen quite a lot more Asylum
applications than the UK
um it's granted to Silence of more
people than the UK France France is also
almost certainly not the port of not the
port of entry into Europe that most of
these people have uh have come to say
they will be potentially have come they
will potentially rather have come from
Italy or from Greece
um prior to Albania or from Albania a
bit proper via Italy or virtually and
then France presumably
um but that Pro that process means that
if you don't if you consistently
basically say well it's not our problem
it's the the country next to us next to
us is problem so France's problem then
you're constantly pushing things back to
another place and that doesn't
necessarily help very much I think it's
also important to recognize that
stopping people from coming over I mean
I think everybody's agreed that people
coming over on boats is extremely
dangerous it's not a desirable scenario
it is a scenario which has been to some
extent created by a suite of actions
that have been taken to try to prevent
irregular migration before so the
securitization of the port of Calais was
undertaken specifically to try to
prevent irregular migration in the first
place and the outcome of that was to
basically push people towards for
towards different approaches to doing
this and those different approaches I
mean the idea realistically was that by
securitizing by secure by adding
security to the port of Calais you
create a barrier which was too dangerous
for people to come to consider so
effectively the risk of death was the
deterrent but unfortunately we should
know that doesn't work and so
recognizing that one has to take steps
that are going to be that are going to
be a little bit more about negotiation
and diplomacy rather than sort of trying
to put a hard line somewhere let let's
see what the view of our our wall is on
that question about it's essentially
about our relations with the French now
I'm going to ask
um our viewers panel this the question
whether you think in reality it is
possible for this government to do
a deal with the French that would
achieve what some of our panelists have
been in the studio been talking about to
find a way through this can we do a deal
with the French those who believe that
Mr sunac Miss bravaman have what it
takes to do that deal with the French
hands up
but those those uh we'll just pan along
a little bit and see because because I'm
actually not seeing anybody who thinks
that it is possible and there are quite
a lot of thumbs down there
thank you
uh
before I go I'm going to come back to
some uh to to Natalie elfic that's
pretty um
conclusive isn't it nobody seems to
think that we can do a deal with the
French well we did see last year that
you know an offer a really sensible
offer was made to president macron
um which he turned down in the after
these Dreadful deaths that happened
about joint patrols but more recently
there have been warmer conversations and
my understanding is that those have been
going much more positively I think it's
absolutely vital that we we take that
action we have that diplomacy that we do
everything we can to stop The Crossings
on the French side all right let's let's
write it out a little bit from our
relations with France and let's talk to
Marzia in Oldham who herself was an
asylum Seeker Marzia
um talk to us about your story
um good evening everyone my name is
Marzia babakiel and I'm a former judge
and women activist from Afghanistan I
was targeted by the Taliban deed buys
tried to kill me and finally I skipped
from my country and came to the UK I put
Asylum and um and 2016 I became a
British citizen when I arrived in the
country I cannot speak a word of English
so I joined the college to learn the
language and learn the culture of this
country and currently I'm working as a
caseworker with uh local mpw drives to
support and help people who need
for me as the best way to welcome
Refugee to give them chance to
contribute and support each other I try
I tried and I'm trying my best to build
Bridges and contribute in this country
and give back
because I count UK like my home
okay Master thank you very much um
Stephen
would you say that this is a perhaps a
more typical story than some of the ones
that are concerning us today
can I just say how inspiring it was to
hear marzia's story that is
um about the spirit of the people who
come here what an amazing person a
female judge in Afghanistan it takes
real courage to be that in the first
place and I just wanted to pay tribute
to mazia for what you've achieved and
how you've come here and learned English
and contributing so much to our society
and and I'm it really is heartwarming to
hear that kind of story I I think that
we have to remember that there are many
many people who are fleeing violence and
persecution and that's what the refugee
system is about we've signed up to that
since the second world war Winston
Churchill played a key role in that so
let's never forget that 75 of the people
who claim asylum in our country are
granted Asylum because they are genuine
refugees what we need is a process to
ensure that those who are not valid
Asylum Seekers are separated out and
sent back to their country of origin but
the system is so clogged up and broken
that the problem with it is that even
brilliant people like Marzia get caught
up in all of the bad
um rides around this whole question we
are going to go on to talk exactly about
that the issue of process
you're watching the great debate up next
vowed to do whatever it takes to reduce
the numbers arriving in small boats
but is the plan to send people to Rwanda
a workable solution or do we need to
find another way I would love to be
having a front page of the telegraph to
fly a plane taking off to Rwanda that's
my dream
[Applause]
[Music]
this game is sort of eye-wateringly mad
and callous we don't think it's immoral
to offer a home to people
more than 1 000 people crossed the
channel over the weekend we know we have
to do more because the numbers are still
completely unacceptable
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
government is confirming that they are
now engaged with Russian soldiers Air
Raid Sirens through the Airways in the
distance artillery Rains Down it feels
very close to the center of this one
they found this Devastation to their
apartment lots of people live here quite
a few of the windows of the houses have
been blown out by the blast
and it feels that it's changing each day
foreign
[Music]
Chief correspondent you either live and
recover or you die
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
welcome back to the great debate where
we're asking how do we solve Britain's
immigration dilemma
to say there are huge challenges for the
home officers putting it mildly the
number of migrants who've crossed the
channel so far this year in small boats
has almost reached 40 000. the
government's now spending
6.8 million pounds a day housing Asylum
seekers in hotels there's a surge in
illegal migration from Albania and the
plan to process people in Rwanda has
been stalled in the courts with
campaigners claiming it's immoral
so what should be the way forward if
there is one
let's talk to Charles koi
um Charles you're in clacton-on-sea
good evening Charles what's your view
uh good evening Trevor I mean what I
have to what I want to say is that uh
Rishi sunak spoke about integrity
and accountability but shortly after I
was appointed to a libraryman a school
secretary a few days after she was being
stuck by um less trust for breaching
ministerial code
swella breviment I think must be forced
to resign
she's a barrister
and also a former Attorney General
now would it be right to say that she
should deal with her own false
appointment into office before she
attempts addressing British migration
issues and the government will
understand
okay Charles uh as ever uh not
mentioning your word that's um
let's see if we can find another point
of view let's say if uh Chris
there's no uh old friend of the program
uh you're an alternate what's what do
you what's your thought about what
Charles has just said
my opinion yet
um they're they're Uganda Rwanda scheme
should work if it's given a chance as a
country it has shown to be Progressive
other countries in the past
has been through the type of war that we
won Rwanda experienced in the 1990s and
94 to 94.
and those countries are functioning on
the global stage
I think that there are organizations who
do not want to promote Africa in a good
light
to suela bravaman the Home Secretary is
the right person to make
very want to see work
okay thank you thank you chrisilda um uh
putting that view forward is uh
courageous if nothing else Natalie elfic
um
Rand has not got a lot of supporters on
our wall
what we've got to see is it was part of
a package of measures brought forward to
try and Tackle this issue and as we've
seen 40 000 people now have come into
the country through the small boats
routes this has been increasing year on
year it's become increasingly difficult
to deal with the process uh backlog as
we've discussed and so you know that the
idea behind this is to make sure that
people are looked after safely in line
with our obligations but also to make
sure that they can be processed quickly
so we can deal with some of those
backlogs that we've got but at the
moment it's stuck in the courts it's you
know people who don't like it have held
it up in the courts and we don't know
how long that's going to take it could
be months it could be more than a year
okay I don't care that
you you heard what somebody said there
about um essentially the reason that
people don't
fancy the right under scheme very much
is that they're dissing Africa
well
I don't think so
it's not about projecting Africa in a
wrong or right way
this is about human beings
but honestly do you think people would
um react in the same way if instead of
Rwanda we were talking about Canada
which quite likes having immigrants I'm
sure people will still react the same
way especially in a place where there's
no oversight
because right here in the UK
we have seen problems from the
government
especially in detention centers where
there is no oversight to see what's
going on there for people that have been
detained how do you monitor people
from here that would be taken to Rwanda
of sharing in fact
we're talking about stopping people
smuggling to me the government is kind
of doing
the same thing wanting to send people to
Rwanda okay which I think it's not right
because in fact when you look at people
that are seeking Asylum that are lgbtiq
that's another problem there okay the
government's impact assessment says that
lgbtiq people are not
safe in Rwanda then why does the
government want to send people to LGBT
that you're saying really yeah no okay
all right let's let's talk again to
Connor Connor Sumrall in Mansfield
aren't you Conor um hello again
um you've got a question for our panel
yeah after seeing that Zoella bradman's
continuing with the immoral Rwanda
policy and are using insensitive
language like The Invasion on our
Southern border that's particularly
insensitive with what's happening in
Ukraine I'm just wondering is she up to
the job of Home Secretary
thank you so much Connor for that direct
question
is swella Brotherman up to the job of
Home Secretary
I'm wondering what you're thinking
Stephen Canuck no she's not
um she should either resign or be sacked
by Rishi sunak she has breached the
ministerial code on a number of
occasions we've also seen they're very
well resourced stories saying that
articles and newspapers and also from
her own back bench MPS Roger Gale the MP
for North thanet in the chamber today
said when Sue Ella bravaman took over
that's when the problems in manston
started because she stopped transferring
people from manston to other hotels that
led to the crisis we have in Manchester
now outbreaks of diphtheria scabies
these are not the sort of things we
should be seeing in 2022 in the United
Kingdom in what is supposed to be a
civilized society so because of her
cruelty and because of her incompetence
uh the Home Secretary should resign one
word if I may or Rwanda it is unworkable
it is unaffordable and it is unethical
it's not acting as a deterrent and it is
costing millions and it's not right to
offload our problems onto a developing
country thousands of miles away okay I'm
going to come to
around the question in a moment but um
Natalie elfick
um do you want to respond on the
specific question about Zoella bravaman
and her
appropriateness well over the uh last
week or so in Dover we've seen these
boat Landings that we've spoken about
and these terrifying instances for
residents in my constituency we've seen
the Dreadful situation of overcrowding
which is at the cause of the problems at
manston and we've also seen the
absolutely horrific fire bombing in the
Dover facility adjust on Sunday which I
do think we should also mention in this
context but what did labor want to talk
about today what do labor want to talk
about all the time they want to talk
about who sowella bravaman sends emails
to I think that my constituents and I
want to talk about how we're going to
get this issue fixed and how we're going
to make sure that we stop the small
boats Crossing crisis and we save lives
okay I'd like to say that but
question he asked is still a problem up
to the job well I think she needs to be
able to focus on the job that she's
doing and that's what I want to see I
want to see us really concentrating on
sorting out the small boats Crossings
it's such an important issue and we need
to make sure that the Home Secretary
not a ringing endorsement there
well I think that we need to see action
taken on the small boats Crossings and
you know as I've set out there are a
number of ways in which we can do that
but the situation that's happened in my
constituency over the last week has been
incredibly serious and it needs urgently
to be addressed all right let's go back
to Rwanda the the random question that
was raised earlier and Rob McNeil
um
is is this Arrangement so unique I mean
I think there are Third Country removals
elsewhere aren't there they there are
some I mean Australia famously undertook
those things they don't do offshoring
anymore they stopped in 2014. I think
the thing with the Rwanda policy that's
worth understanding is that it's
effectively a symbolic policy it's about
sending a message about what the UK is
going to do rather than actually doing
something substantial the number of
people that are going to be that would
potentially be removed to Rwanda is
extremely small compared to the number
of people that are arriving on small
boats so the presumption is that it's
going to act as a deterrent now as we
were discussing earlier on I mean the
the presumption that the sea would act
that the sea and that that the risk of
death would act as a deterrent and stop
people from crossing over with the
securitization of the port of Calais was
not successful there's no real evidence
that the Rwanda that the deterrent
effect of the Rwanda policy will be
necessarily effective and what we do
know is it's extremely expensive and
something of a distraction from what may
maybe the really sort of the really big
problems that should be addressed such
as the clearing of the Asylum backlog
and clearing the Asylum backlog is in
everybody's interest is extraordinarily
expensive for the country to to have to
deal with huge with more than a hundred
thousand that's what I'm Seekers that's
a very important Point what what is the
key to that because we now know that the
average uh time taken to turn around an
application I think is today 480 days
ago the best part of a year and a half
but why is it what takes so long well
it's very difficult question to answer
what we do know is that there was a
service standard that was expected that
was abandoned in 2019 and that service
standard was that 80 of Asylum claims
would be processed within six months
because that was dropped in early 2019
or after that was dropped in early 2019
we saw a very very substantial decline
in processing time or an increase in
processing times so that last year I
mean so in 2018 80 87 of
um 87 of Asylum claims were processed
within all were initial process initial
claims were processed within six months
in 2021 that was it was down to six
percent so the the key the home office
does need to focus on spending money
where that money is going to be best and
most effective okay thank you very much
you're watching the great debate coming
up after the break Britain's employers
are complaining they can't get the staff
should it be easier to hire migrants
workers have been in short supply and
many doubt British agriculture can grow
if it's foreign labor force shrinks
shorter's labor of cost us a quarter
million pounds in May the idea that you
can overnight close down the borders and
not allow in critical skills that we
clearly aren't going to grow in Britain
soon that's just putting growth second
not first immigration has to reflect the
needs of the economy I recognize it's a
big issue for businesses but they've got
to accept that the public have concerns
about that too
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're asking how do we solve Britain's
immigration dilemma
from telecoms to farming to construction
to the Health and Social care sectors
their staff shortages record vacancies
might seem like a good idea to some
means low employment unemployment
but companies are struggling to fill the
jobs and that means they can't grow so
should we turn to migrants to plug the
gaps let's talk to Cheryl in Bournemouth
Cheryl you um work in a nursery I think
I do I run a group of day nurseries and
we are desperately short of Staff which
means that we are having to turn parents
away and with their children
so we see immigration as a really good
way to bring graduates into the country
but there are massive hold UPS we're not
even on the short staff list with the
home office so I've got a question
um you know how can we use immigration
to fill this Gap or how else can we fill
the labor shortage that we've gotten you
know thank you thank you Cheryl uh
Louise Brown in Sunderland
um
do you have the same problem
um I think that we do need more
immigration yes
um since brexit there's been huge gaps
and services due to shortage of staff so
here in Sunderland we used to have lots
of Polish bus drivers for example and
now a lot have returned home
um the buses simply don't run properly
and are very unreliable and I'm dreading
getting on them tomorrow
it's not just buses though there's also
shortages everywhere and so Agriculture
and food industry and British workers
clearly don't always want to fill these
roles
hold that thought Louise because I think
it's a very important Point Rob McNeil
um it's a big problem isn't it
well it's certainly a challenge but I
mean a lot of this is about low-skilled
migration when I say low skilled I mean
I don't want to be pejorative about this
we're just talking about jobs that don't
require a lot of training to to before
you qualify to do them
um but that's those are the people that
can't come into the country now and
that's effectively as a result of brexit
brexit people voted specifically to try
and reduce the number of low-skilled
migrants in coming into the UK and that
was very specifically the objective of
the policy it was the objective of
brexit you know the government has
basically said they want to move to a
high skill High wage economy and so yes
I mean it creates serious problems
um but the question is are those the
problems that are those problems that
people are willing to accept in return
for lower migration particularly lower
skilled migration okay uh Stephen
kinnick it's part of the problem here
British workers are well they don't want
to do certain jobs but they also don't
want too many migrants because the
unions think that they bring down wages
you need a balance we're not going to
back go back to free movement of Labor
that's clear that's clearly Labor's
policy we need a point-based immigration
system but we need one that's based on
proper dialogue between trade unions and
the government and employers so that you
have a Workforce plan on a
sector-by-sector basis and that plan
says this is the amount of immigration
we're going to need and this is how
we're going to train up our local
workers and pay them properly thus
making it more attractive to Homegrown
talent but without letting the in the
sector collapse because you don't it's
immigration to come in but as a net
result of that that actually we will
have more immigrants more migrants doing
work I see it as a balancing out so that
you will need in some sectors
immigration to ensure that the sector
can keep functioning and we're seeing
real problems in Hospitality in Health
and Social care in agriculture but so
bring the migrants in but make sure that
you make the employers give you a proper
Workforce plan with proper recruitment
proper way of putting wages up
developing skills and productivity
that's the deal that the government
should be doing with trade unions and
employers so that over over a Time cycle
maybe two three years you're reducing
immigration and increasing homegrown
talent and opportunities what you can't
though do is just turn the tap off
because that's really dangerous for the
sector and for the economy all right I
wish we could talk about it more but we
can't we have to go to a break you're
watching the great debate there are no
civil silver bullets to this immigration
dilemma but has even talking about it
become too scary should we can we start
a more honest conversation about the
future of immigration they've come to
seek work in Britain and are ready and
willing to do any kind of job that will
help the motherland along the road to
prosperity
there is no doubt that on the doorstep
in local communities immigration has
suddenly become very high in the agenda
all these Eastern Europeans were coming
in
immigration across the board which party
is serious about stopping the invasion
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
we had the British women's team late
last night and they finished
qualification in second place so they'll
be heading into the Team final tomorrow
and uh the boys team start about half
past 11 this morning so uh yeah fingers
crossed they'll have a great day the
results have been coming through and
obviously getting better and better over
the past few years we've had a
magnificent Summer with the Commonwealth
Games the European championships Joe
Fraser becoming European champion and so
obviously I think their confidence going
into this championships is really high
there's a number of factors I mean it's
taken a long time since
um the results have come through and we
targeted the younger gymnasts obviously
when they first came through the program
you started to get results back in sort
of 2002 and then obviously that starts
to create a belief within the team you
start to have role models for younger
gymnasts coming through the athletes are
lottery funded which massively helps
they only focus solely on their
gymnastics and not having to to worry
about a career outside of gymnastics and
then obviously they get the support
behind that whether that's the medical
support the coaching support the
facilities and be able to travel the
world to do all of the tournaments to to
get that exposure and that experience a
lot of the stars that you're going to
see here in Liverpool are going to be
the stars of that Olympics in two years
time and for me it's obviously really
special to be here in Liverpool this is
where I did most of my training
literally five minutes down the road and
so to see that the British team here
competing all the young gymnasts and the
audience they've got a fan Zone here
which has been incredible so many young
gymnasts getting opportunities to to
meet with the British team to have a go
on some of the activities so it's really
inspirational for that younger
generation coming through
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're asking how do we solve Britain's
immigration dilemma
is the first Home Secretary to run into
trouble over immigration
uh she probably won't be the last every
government promises to grasp the nettle
but the issue never seems to be solved
well still it's one of the topics that
seems to make every politician
uncomfortable
so can we ever have an open and honest
National debate without finger-pointing
and accusations of racism let's see if
we can start that let's talk to Ray
Price in I gather and rainy Neath in
South Wales
it is indeed Trevor it's absolutely
hammering down here
um good evening grieving panel
um
yes uh do we need more honesty from our
politicians when it comes to immigration
as they seem to promise everything but
deliver nothing
I don't care
not a politician
thank you for the question I think that
is very very important
the politicians should be very very
Frank and honest with everybody it is
time to break down the system that is in
operation right now because they're just
not working
it's just too convoluted it's got to be
broken and people need to be honest
about it and face reality and make sure
that everybody has honest debate and
contribution into how it works for
instance I just go back to life before
we went on break
just to add to what Stephen said we are
talking about people working there are
people in this country also who are
seeking Asylum that are not allowed to
work and they have good skills brilliant
skills that they can contribute into
this country why are they not been
allowed to work
actually that is a question that I think
it would be good to put to our viewers
panel
um
adironke has just asked the question
should Asylum Seekers be allowed to work
she says they have skills other people
say that that would encourage people uh
to take this route let's see
those who think that Asylum Seekers
ought to be able to be allowed to work
if they are in the country hands up
those who think that they ought to be
able to to work
and we're going to
well that's very that is very
interesting that is very interesting
um an overwhelming majority then Natalie
alfik think that if Asylum Seekers make
it into the country while they're
waiting for their Refugee status to be
regularized or not they should be
allowed to work what do you think I
think it's really important for having
that honest conversation to look at why
people are coming uh into the into the
country particularly on the small boats
routes we know that the majority at the
moment are coming from Albania are
economic migrants rather than Asylum
Seekers as most people would understand
it so it is about work and about those
draws to work so I think it's really
important that that we just bear that in
mind uh Stephen both um
labor governments and conservative
governments in the past have held the
line on this one and said Asylum Seekers
can't work well Asylum Seekers are
allowed to work after 12 months our
position has actually been and we tried
to amend the nationality and borders
bill on this to reduce that to six
months we've we believe that every
single Asylum claim should be processed
within six months and every person
should be a given leave to remain if
they have passed the and granted Asylum
and be able to work from six months the
government refused our Amendment and
insisted that it should be 12 months in
the labor position you think that
actually at some point they ought to be
able to work even if they haven't got
Refugee status yet yes no well we want
all Refugee processing to happen within
six months but even if it hasn't from
six months onward they should be allowed
to work um the current ruling is they
can work after 12 months but only in the
shortage occupation lists thank you very
much indeed that is all we have time for
this evening uh I think
I just want to uh say thank you to all
our panelists this evening
and I'm going to actually before we go
before we go I just want to check with
our viewers panel
um Stephen kinnick says that actually we
could have uh the opportunity for Asylum
Seekers to work
before they've got full status let's
just quickly see
who agrees with that position who thinks
that would be a good thing to do
yeah and we've got a majority there
thank you for giving me the extra time
to to be able to do that
um that is actually all we have time for
this evening now and it now it just
remains for me to say thank you to our
panelists here in the studio
Robert McNeil
adironke apata
Stephen kinnick
and Natalie elfig
of course all of you who are watching at
home are always at the heart of our
conversation and many of you may want to
join in the program at some point so the
way you can do that is to email us send
your emails to the great debate at
sky.uk
and we are going to be here every week
until the end of November I want to say
thank you to our viewers panel
okay and for you at home I want to thank
you for joining us this evening keep
talking and we'll see you again at the
same time next week for the great debate
foreign
[Applause]